para impulsar las soluciones.
Hablemos de lo que deberían hacer las empresas.
Y cuando digo eso,
probablemente piensan que hablaré sobre filantropía corporativa
o de la responsabilidad social corporativa.
La RSC es la norma hoy,
y es muy útil.
Proporciona una ruta para la generosidad corporativa
y esa generosidad es importante para los empleados de muchas corporaciones
y clientes.
¿Pero saben qué?
Simplemente no es lo bastante grande,
lo bastante fuerte
o lo bastante resistente
para impulsar soluciones a los mayores problemas actuales de nuestro mundo
porque se trata de un costo incremental.
Incluso cuando el negocio está en auge,
la RSC simplemente no está diseñada para escalar.
Y luego, por supuesto, en una recesión
es una de las primeras cosas que se recortan.
Así que
la CSR,
la responsabilidad social corporativa,
no es la respuesta,
pero sí el TSI,
el impacto social total.
El TSI es la suma de todas las formas
de negocio que puede afectar a la sociedad
haciendo el trabajo real:
al pensar en sus cadenas de suministro,
al diseñar sus productos, procesos de fabricación
y su distribución.
El verdadero trabajo de los negocios
tras haber terminado con la innovación,
realmente puede crear beneficios comerciales centrales para la compañía
y puede resolver los problemas significativos actuales de nuestro mundo.
Y, ¿cómo es el TSI?
Si nos centramos en el TSI,
significa incorporar consideraciones sociales y ambientales.
¿Y saben qué?
Es algo que no es completamente nuevo.
Ya fue pensado hace un tiempo.
Pero la parte más difícil es que las empresas siguen pensando
casi exclusivamente en algo llamado TSR:
el rendimiento total para los accionistas.
Pero el TSI,
el impacto social total,
necesita estar al lado del TSR
como un importante y válido impulsor de la estrategia corporativa
y la toma de decisiones corporativas.
Y tenemos los datos para mostrarle por qué y cómo
algunas compañías ya hacen que esto suceda.
Están logrando que esto suceda.
Así que déjenme contarte la historia de Marte.
Marte es la sexta compañía privada más grande de EE. UU.
Si son como yo,
pensarán que Marte hace algunos productos importantes,
como el café y el chocolate.
Así que no sorprende
que uno de sus ingredientes más importantes sea el cacao.
Y algunos de sus competidores realmente están preocupados
sobre la sostenibilidad y disponibilidad de suministro de cacao.
Pero no en Marte,
porque confían en el suministro estable de ese cultivo a largo plazo.
¿Y por qué esto es así?
Es porque se asocian con ONGs de todo el mundo
que trabajan con pequeños agricultores accionistas.
Y las ONGs de esas agencias certificadas
trabajan para ayudar a los agricultores a mejorar el rendimiento de los cultivos,
asegurándose de que reciban un salario justo para vivir.
Y les ayudan a abordar todo problema potencial de derechos humanos
en las cadenas de suministro,
y ayudan a minimizar los efectos sobre el medio ambiente,
como la deforestación.
Marte está en el camino de lograr el 100 % de cacao certificado.
Se trata de un buen programa para comunidades agrícolas,
es un buen programa para el medio ambiente,
y es un buen programa para Marte,
quién ha resuelto un riesgo significativo en su cadena de suministro.
Pero veamos los datos,
porque son realmente increíbles.
Y déjenme explicar exactamente qué tipo de datos son de los que hablaré.
Cuando los analistas y las personas financieras miran las compañías,
piensan en muchas estadísticas diferentes.
Quiero hablar de dos de las más importantes.
Voy a hablar sobre el valor general de una empresa:
su valoración.
y voy a hablar sobre su margen.
Básicamente es la diferencia entre todas sus ganancias
y todos sus costos.
En nuestro estudio,
analizamos las compañías de petróleo y gas,
y las compañías de petróleo y gas
con mayor TSI,
es decir, con mayor impacto social total.
Así hay una prima del 19 % en su valoración,
19 %.
cuando lo hacen realmente bien
minimizando el impacto de su empresa
en el medio ambiente y el agua,
y cuando tienen programas muy fuertes de salud y seguridad ocupacional.
Y cuando también agregan programas sólidos de formación de empleados
obtienen una prima de 3.4 puntos porcentuales en sus márgenes.
Pero, ¿y otras industrias?
Las empresas biofarmacéuticas con los mejores resultados en ETI
ven una prima del 12 % en su valoración.
Y luego, si son mejores para expandir el acceso a los medicamentos,
es decir, que logran que los medicamentos estén disponibles
para las personas que los necesitan
ven una prima de 6.7 puntos porcentuales en sus márgenes brutos.
Para los bancos minoristas que son más fuertes en TSI,
ven una prima de tres puntos porcentuales en su valoración,
y luego para aquellos que ofrecen inclusión financiera diferencialmente
acceso a productos financieros para las personas que lo necesitan,
ven una prima de 0.5 puntos porcentuales en su margen de ingreso neto.
Estos números para los bancos pueden no parecer muy grandes,
pero en industrias altamente competitivas,
incluso las pequeñas diferencias en el margen importan mucho.
Y, ¿qué pasa con esas empresas de bienes de consumo
las que hacen los productos que nos encantan como el café y el chocolate?
Las empresas de bienes de consumo
con mejor rendimiento en el impacto social total
logran una prima de valuación del 11 %.
Y luego, si hacen esas cosas inteligentes con su cadena de suministro,
abastecimiento inclusivo y responsable de su producto,
ven una prima de 4,8 puntos porcentuales en sus márgenes brutos.
Estos números son significativos.
Hace tiempo que sabemos que cosas como finanzas fundamentales,
las tasas de crecimiento y los riesgos financieros
son los principales factores de valoración.
Pero este análisis riguroso muestra que los factores sociales y ambientales,
las medidas totales de impacto social,
también están vinculados a valoraciones y márgenes.
Guau.
Todo lo demás continúa igual,
no confundimos el análisis con nada.
En igualdad de condiciones,
empresas con gran rendimiento en áreas sociales y ambientales
logran mayores márgenes
y valoraciones más altas.
Entiendo que
las empresas están bajo gran presión por obtener ganancias a corto plazo.
Pero afortunadamente,
los inversores que crean algo de esta presión
en realidad cada vez más ellos mismos comienzan a pensar a más largo plazo
y a pensar con esta lente TSI.
En nuestras conversaciones y encuestas con inversores,
el 75 % de ellos dice que espera ver una mejora en los ingresos
y una mejor eficiencia operativa
para las empresas que están pensando con una lente TSI.
Y en realidad están comenzando a incorporar esto
en su propio comportamiento de inversión.
El año pasado,
23 mil millones en activos globales
estaban en la categoría de inversión socialmente responsable.
Eso significa 5 mil millones en los últimos dos años.
Lo que representa una cuarta parte del total
de activos globales gestionados en el mundo.
Sé que algunos de Uds. se estarán encogiendo de hombros en este momento.
Porque en mis décadas de consultoría estratégica
con empresas, ONGs y gobiernos de todo el mundo,
encuentro que muchos empresarios
dudan en hablar o incluso en pensar
sobre los beneficios comerciales de hacer el bien.
De alguna manera piensan que negarán valor
a los beneficios que están creando para la sociedad.
O que serán percibidos como desalmados o incluso mercenarios.
Pero realmente debemos pensar diferente.
Necesitamos pensar diferente
porque la única forma en que lograremos un progreso sustancial
en los desafiantes problemas de nuestro tiempo
es que las empresas impulsen las soluciones.
La misión de las empresas es satisfacer las necesidades del cliente
y hacerlo de manera rentable.
Se necesita para sobrevivir.
Y, una de las mejores maneras para que las empresas ayuden a asegurar
su propio crecimiento, su propia longevidad,
es enfrentar algunos de los desafíos más difíciles en nuestra sociedad
y hacerlo de manera rentable.
Y cuando lo hacen de forma innovadora,
cuando lo hacen de forma ética, responsable, increíble,
deberían estar orgullosos.
Pero si aún no están seguro de esto,
veamos algunos ejemplos más.
¿Qué pasa si eres una empresa de tecnología
e intentas hacer crecer tu plataforma
y tu cartera de clientes?
Como Airbnb.
Airbnb tiene una cartera de actividades de impacto social total.
Todos son puntuales en su negocio principal.
En una iniciativa,
ayudan a habilitar su comunidad
para proporcionar viviendas gratis a aquellos envueltos en tragedias:
sobrevivientes de crisis y trabajadores humanitarios.
En otro esfuerzo de su parte,
en realidad ayudan y trabajan con ONGs
para garantizar que las personas puedan proporcionar
viviendas gratuitas a refugiados.
Lo que me encanta de este programa
es que no creo que la mayoría de la gente se habría dado cuenta de
cómo expresar su generosidad
abriendo sus hogares a aquellos en necesidad extrema,
ciertamente no tan rápido o tan fácil o eficientemente,
sin esta innovación de Airbnb.
Pero al mismo tiempo,
esto es esencial para su estrategia corporativa
y fundamental para su crecimiento
porque crecen al aumentar la cantidad de alojados e invitados
usando su plataforma.
Pero si solo hubieran pensado exclusivamente
en retorno de inversión,
no creo que alguna vez habrían descubierto esta ruta
hacia el crecimiento, porque no cobran tarifas de transacción.
Y es una forma muy emocionante
cuando estaban pensando en cómo aplicar sus competencias
a una necesidad en la sociedad
y al mismo tiempo impulsar su propio crecimiento.
Pero, ¿qué sucede si se trata de encontrar nuevos segmentos de clientes?
Cambiemos a Sudáfrica,
y hablemos de Standard Bank.
En Sudáfrica,
el gobierno tiene una regulación
eso requiere que todos los bancos donen el 0.2 % de sus ganancias
a pequeñas y medianas empresas con propietarios negros.
Y muchos bancos simplemente donan esto a los empresarios,
pero Standard Bank pensó creativamente.
Y lo que hicieron es tomar esos fondos
y los invirtieron en un fideicomiso independiente,
y usaron esa confianza para financiar préstamos a estos empresarios negros.
Este es un modelo muy apoyado.
Este facilita el apoyo a muchos más empresarios con capital,
y su éxito está completamente relacionado
con el éxito de los empresarios,
en realidad también utilizan el fondo para proporcionar asistencia técnica.
Con más empresarios apoyados,
hay más personas y comunidades sacadas de la pobreza.
Y es exitoso para Standard Bank.
Tan exitoso que en realidad están trabajando para expandir este programa
a otras áreas en su cartera.
No es que no hayamos intentado resolver los problemas en nuestro mundo
por mucho tiempo.
Lo hemos hecho y seguimos haciéndolo.
Estamos progresando,
pero no es suficiente,
lo bastante rápido,
o lo bastante universal.
Necesitamos cambiar nuestro pensamiento.
Necesitamos tener empresas,
compañías e inversores
con una estrategia corporativa creativa y capital
para resolver los mayores problemas en nuestro mundo.
Y cuando lo hacen de forma innovadora,
y cuando lo hacen
con todos sus pensamientos y toda su estrategia
y todo su capital,
crean rendimientos totales para los accionistas
además de impacto social total,
sabiendo que resolveremos esos problemas,
tanto de manera rentable como generosa.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)